it does come with age i do see things
different
i know that he was not an alcoholic and
he was not drunk
when he struck that bridge i can
guarantee everybody had he been drunk
and had alcohol in his system they would
have detected it and he would have he
would have
you know just been guilty
i've seen a different side since i've
been involved with reliving this
he had there was no way he could have
done anything different because he was
already on such a trajectory through
that channel
with the wind and the weather
all the elements that were involved he
couldn't stop the ship because the ship
would have just sailed right into
another piling he had no choice but to
try his best and thread the needle
again there's
even today there's so much discussion on
what he could have done what he should
have done what he may have done
best thing would have been not to even
go
that morning and leave the the safety of
the open water where they had pumped the
boat out right make it lighter however
he did choose to had he had a current
updated accurate weather forecast from
ruskin
notifying him that there was a potential
weather bomb
headed in his direction with cyclonic
winds shortly i'm pretty sure that he
would not have even left to go in to the
bay however he did
that decision was made he did the best
he could
it was considered an act of god had he
not taken the actions that he did by
throwing it into reverse dropping the
anchors
there's no doubt in my mind had he
completely ignored all of that and kept
on plowing through that he would have
more than likely taken down the second
bridge
he probably would have taken down both
bridges if he didn't take the actions
that he did right i think he did a
fantastic job
based on
what he had to work with
and isn't it true that the weather
report didn't even come in until like an
hour after he struck the bridge
absolutely or so absolutely that's why i
say if he would have had proper
communications like they do today i'm
sure it wouldn't happen the radar was a
complete whiteout or blackout or
whiteout
there was there was no other vessels
that could give him any advice on the
conditions ahead the other vessel that
was headed out
that had a full load of oil
was called the pure oil
was headed out at the same time at about
7 30 in the morning
he saw the weather
he didn't get a forecast he diverted his
ship out of the shipping channel and
actually anchored up and waited for the
storm to pass
really yes
it was called the pure oil
it's it's pretty well documented in the
newspaper and they were leaving the
docks going out to see he was headed out
with a full load of oil i
shudder to think
what would have happened had he
not
pulled out and anchored up i think he
stopped i want to say less than a half a
mile or a mile from the bridge on the
east side on the inside had he not
stopped and done what he did
he either would have been under it in it
on top of it or whatever with a load of
oil and i can only imagine the potential
impact the environmental impact damage
from that so like i said there there
were plenty of stories out there and
plenty of
uh conditions that uh you know people
make choices everybody made a choice on
that day and that was the choice and
that's what's the results
i guarantee that you know there's no way
he intentionally did that or or that he
was drunk that's that's still disgusting
to this day to hear that yeah you're
it's a good point you made it could have
been way worse if he would have done
something different not put it in
reverse and not through the anchors down
he could have definitely hit that second
span he killed way more people and
taking both bridges out and completely
shut down the economy and and everything
from south
absolutely
so how long
how many times after that day did you
guys go out consecutively
i'm gonna guess we were out there for
about two weeks i know we were out here
the next day on the 10th we started
measurements we started
photography
we swam every inch of that thing as it
was down
on may 11th
which was mother's day
is when they brought that bus up finally
we were out there on mother's day we
were within a couple hundred yards of
that location it was very difficult
there was a lot of for whatever reason
boat traffic and
you got to call them what it is gawkers
that just wouldn't stay away the coast
guard and the marine patrol had a very
difficult time people keeping people
away from that location as they were
trying to raise the bus right they had
brought in a derrick and a floating
barge and they lifted eventually the bus
up onto that location on mother's day
mother's day on that evening at that
time i was married and i had two
children
and i can guarantee you that when i went
home on mother's day my wife got an
extra big hug and a kiss
not only that day but the every day for
about two weeks afterwards when i went
out there
i know that
mike's fiance
at the time mike's fiance at the time
probably would have skinned me alive if
she could have caught me
realizing what i had put
mike through and what i had put mike
done right on that day and the following
day and the next day i know it was
difficult for mike and i know it still
is for both of us
we were out there a good two weeks
gathering information not only for the
d.o.t but also for like i said earlier
the national transportation safety board
we had completed a report and put it
together it was published i think june
of 1980
when did you guys get this thing
and how much does this weigh
i'm guessing it's i my weight i'm
guessing it's 38 pounds
more than that bob this thing is like
could be
that is one of four large anchor bolts
that anchored the
bearing pad
to the top of pier one
south
there were four of those that were
holding a pad probably about the size of
this table
a concrete pad on top of the concrete
this is one i'm going to give you a
picture of
yeah that essentially is the means of
securing the truss to the concrete piers
that's a big-ass nut here it
is yeah
i'm gonna show you this but i've got a
better picture
[Music]
this is the pier
pier one north there's a small speck on
top of that you may not be able to see
it but that's the remaining bearing pad
the other bearing pad was on this side
when the bridge was pulled off in this
direction
it pulled itself
completely free
of the bearing pad by snapping four
of these large bolts
in a nano second
it's sheared it's just like a superman
ripped that
four of those
and this is what that was one that's the
that's the remaining bolt was four feet
into the embedded four feet into the
concrete jesus the noise
that that bridge would have made
when that thing went down because all of
that metal snapped and buckled and
rivets were flying hundreds of yards
away and steel was flying and that thing
squealed and cried the whole way down so
that was one of four that was completely
sheared
we recovered all four of those and on
that particular day i think we swam up
of course we were both younger then but
how could you swim
up 50 feet with one of these in your
hands bob could i had to tie the i don't
think i could walk the line and pull it
up with a rope that's what we did for
your commercial divers that's what we
did i was a good swimmer so you must
have been jacked we uh we were able to
recover four of those and this is one
eventually i'm thinking about donating
and maybe to the museum over in tampa
there's a skyway museum well i think
about that my kids my grandkids may want
to but this is one of four that was
snapped
that's unbelievable instantly that's why
i say the the the tremendous energy that
it must have taken and the noise that it
made when that thing popped and let go
must have been
tremendous
tremendous oh yeah
not to mention all the small rivers
absolutely how long does it take for
them to start rebuilding in the new
bridge
well you're
that
how long did it take them to start
rebuilding the new bridge they didn't
rebuild the new bridge they they built a
new structure that was opened in 87.
so it took seven years yeah it took
seven years for the construction and
that was after the completion of what
type of design and who was going to
build it and uh what type et cetera et
cetera
they were able to use the northbound
bridge to
uh
correct so they just split up they
barricaded it off and and signed it up
and stuff and they carry traffic for
until 1987 when it was finally uh blown
up and destroyed
wow
and of course the fishing piers are
still there the remains of the original
bridges
now the seven years seven years later
when they started to construct
the new bridge were you guys involved in
any of the inspections of that bob
weren't you telling me you were showing
me a photo you were telling me they
wanted you to dive down inside of like a
tube where they were pouring concrete
underwater
yes
yes yeah let me uh
what's it called coffee dairy coffee
damn a coffer dam yeah essentially they
take steel sheet piling that are
interlockable
and they pound them into the ground form
a complete circle and they can pump that
out and have have a dry area okay right
in the middle of the bay so they can
start drilling their uh foundation
supports oh wow yeah
how do you want to do this just hold it
up
you can hold it on the chair if you want
all right well
there's the copper down okay
this is one of the bearing piling that
they used case on that they drilled into
the ground anywhere from 80 to 100 feet
it's about eight feet in diameter
because there's a human being right
there about eight feet in diameter i
think there was about 44 of those
scattered around
the perimeter
that's nuts
of the main piers of the two main peers
that that's the one that they wanted us
to go inside and check to see if it was
okay and didn't collapse
that's insane man that's wild well what
made this even more challenging is that
these are just
unprotected steel okay and so they they
get rust oxidation on them
even below the water
and so if you go into one of these and
create any turbulence at all that
oxidation on the sides
comes off the sides and
immediately clouds the water so you have
zero visibility can't see a thing can't
see your hand this far from your front
right
how deep do those things go
um they
what they did was they had determined
how deep they needed to go each one may
have varied but you can let's just wait
till you get back to the microphone so
we can hear you
[Music]
they were used as bearing pile to
support that tremendous weight so they
had determined a predetermined elevation
they were averaging like
usually 80 to 100 and some feet
before they were satisfied that they
would hold the bearing i'm not sure
because there were 44 of them and they
were a neat pier or something there was
a bunch they had varying elevations
yeah man it's amazing to me that
there was a time when they wouldn't
think of having something to protect
bridges from these massive tanker or
these massive cargo ships that were
going through just like these giant
objects that could easily destroy this
bridge that people drive over every day
like like you see now obviously those
big rounds
whatever they are this big concrete
bumpers they have they call them
dolphins that's correct they're called
dolphins golf and shrek correct it's
amazing to me that they weren't they
no one could think of that before this
had to happen unfortunately that's part
of the the history of the inspection
program like i say it started with a
tragedy in the ankle river and the
developer program
this tragedy
changed the way they looked at building
and protecting bridges just like you
said
after this occurred they had determined
that it was inadequately protected so
they made special efforts to put in
those large dolphins which you know will
sustain most any impact that's what they
were designed for
it affected bridges being built
everywhere not just in the united states
but all across the country they use that
uh as an example for protection and
stuff so it did cause tragedy did cause
a lot of advances in bridge inspections
bridge building and bridge construction
materials now this was also the biggest
bridge
disaster or a bridge accident in history
this was the largest bridge ship
collision accident in history and us
history that's correct
and this i mean
the bridge the skyway bridge is like a
monument and an icon to florida like
even you'll see on you go to any gas
station and
any florida post card has a big
picture of the sun and then a big
outline of the skyway bridge i mean it's
like a monument for florida yeah
it's considered an icon i think it's
considered one of the top ten bridges in
the united states for aesthetics and
stuff
it's very nice they just put uh
yeah can be seen at night when it's all
lit up it's all lit up now i've never
been i mean i've driven over it but i've
never like been in a boat under it
at night yeah they spent uh millions of
dollars on
led lighting
that
shifts uh
make different colors patterns american
flag it's very beautiful they've done
that to many of the bridges many of the
bridges that bridge accident also caused
like i say special
safety features now and all the larger
bridges electronic monitoring sensors to
tell if there's any vibrations or
separations in the spans to prevent that
kind of stuff they've done tremendous
amount of improvements in regards to
safety on large structures like that
you